i believe that uh there's a picture of
you floating in microgravity uh when
when did you get to experience that what
was that like yeah so i've flown nine
times on the affectionately known as the
vomit comet
it's the parabolic flight and
essentially it does what you'd want to
play never to do it pitches really
steeply upwards at 45 degrees that's a
picture you yeah yeah that's test rate
that's super early in my phd some of
just the passive tiles before we even
put electronics in we were just testing
the magnet polarity and the
essentially is it an energy favorable
structure to self-assemble on its own so
we tweaked a lot of things between are
we looking at a couple of them
yeah you're looking at a bunch of them
there's also almost 32
can you comment on what's the difference
between microgravity and and zero
gravity yes so there is
it's important difference there is no
zero gravity there's no nothing there's
in the universe there is no such thing
as zero gravity so newton's law of
gravity tells us that there's always
gravity attraction between any two
objects so zero g is a shorthand that
some of us fall into using is a little
easier to communicate to the public the
accurate term is microgravity where you
are essentially floating you're
weightless but generally in free fall
so on the parabolic flights the vomit
comet you're in free fall at the end of
the parabola and in orbit around the
earth when you're floating you're also
in free fall
so affectionately call vomit comment i'm
sure there's a reason why it's called
affectionately so so what's it like
what's uh your first time
to both philosophically spiritually and
biologically what's it like it's
profound it is
unlike anything else you will experience
on earth
because it is this true feeling of
weightlessness with no drag
so the closest experience you can think
of would be floating in a pool but you
move slowly when you float in a pool and
your motion is restricted when you're
floating it's just you and your body
flying like in a dream
it takes the littlest amount of energy
like a finger tap against the wall of
the plane to shoot all the way across
the fuselage wow and you can move at
full speed like you're you can move your
arms exactly your muscles there's no
yeah there's no resistance
they actually tell you to make a memory
when you're on the plane because it's
such a fleeting experience for your body
that even a few days later you've
already forgotten exactly what it felt
like it's so foreign to the human
experience they kind of suggest that you
explicitly try to really form this into
a membrane and then you can do the
replay cognitively freeze it yeah
save right uh when we have neural link
we can replay that um
that memory so in terms of how much
stress it has on your body is it uh
biologically stressful
you do feel a 2g pullout right so the
cost of getting those uh micro g
parabolas is you then have a 2g pullout
and that's hard you have to train for it
if you move your neck too quickly in
that 2g pull out you can strain muscles
but i wouldn't say that it's
actually a a profound
tough thing on the body it's really just
an incredibly novel experience
and when you're in orbit and you're not
having to go through the ups and downs
of the parabolic plane there's a real
grace and elegance and you see the
astronauts learn to operate in this
completely new environment
what are some interesting differences
between the parabolic plane and when
you're actually going up in orbit
is is it that with orbit you can look
out and see yeah that blue little planet
of ours you can see the blue marble the
stunning overview effect which is
something i hope to see one day what's
also really different is if you're in
orbit for any significant period of time
there's going to be a lot more
physiological changes to your body than
if you just did an afternoon flight on
the vomit comet everything from your
bones your muscles your eyeballs change
shape
there's a lot of different things that
happen for long duration space flight
and we still have to as scientists we
still have to solve a lot of these
interesting challenges to be able to
keep humans
thriving in microgravity or deep
duration space missions
you